je suis venu en précipitant à la fenêtre
parce que je suis compris que c'était
des tirs j'ai vu la voiture là juste
devant le bâtiment était carrément
rentrer dans le bâtiment
il y un peu plus de 15 heures ce mardi
quand une fusillade éclate cette mère de
famille dévale alors les escaliers car
ces enfants sont en train de jouer juste
en bas c'est là qu'elle découvre sa
fille est mis à terre avec une balle
dans la jambe
aujourd'hui elle est en colère je suis
très énervé parce que ça fait des mois
et des mois qu'on appelle au secours on
appelle au secours on nous demande de
nous aider mais personne n'a voulu nos
enfants on savait qu'on allait en
arriver là
un climat anxiogène rennes depuis des
semaines dans cette cité du creusot à
cause de trafiquants de drogue
nous ses peurs on aimerait d'allumer la
lumière quand on rentrait soir parce que
ça se passe souvent ils sont tout en bas
il s'était h 24 et 6 étaient logés dans
les escaliers il avait une chaise dans
les escaliers toute la famille a décidé
de déménager car la victime de 14 ans
traumatisée ne veux plus rentrer chez
elle l'oncle de l'adolescente est
revenue dans la cité juste après le
drame il constate avec tristesse que les
enfants ont déserté les espaces verts
comment une certaine insécurité dans
notre quartier et c'est vrai que depuis
des années ça s'est amplifié on a
l'impression que personne ne fait rien
dans l'impression que ça s'est
normalisée la mairie du creusot a ouvert
une cellule d'urgence médico
psychologique
parmi les participants ont beaucoup
d'enfants témoin de la fusillade
ils ont pu s'exprimer devant des
professionnels de santé d'autres sont
venus par soutien et les langues se sont
déliées
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait d'un peu plus
de renforts de police en même temps dans
le quartier
avec une surveillance jour et nuit ça
c'est pas mal parce qu'ils ont beau
mettre des caméras dans les halls comme
ça soit ça se fait pas de nombreux
habitants sous le choc souhaiterait
aujourd'hui partir de la cité du tennis